thirty-six hours till polls open then
this is the grim spectacle that
Ukraine's election season Petro
poroshenko battling to hold on to his
presidency against Volodymyr zalenski a
comedian with no political know-how
whose streaks ahead in the polls I am
NOT a politician I am NOT a politician
at all I am just a human being an
ordinary human being who has come to
break this system I am the result Petro
poroshenko of your mistakes and promises
Petro poroshenko traded on his
experience five years as commander in
chief in a grinding war in Ukraine's
East and on the suggestion that his
opponent is little more than a blank
canvas with a few policies to speak
today we just see a beautiful candy
wrapper which is expensive and bright
and everyone sees in it what they want
to see earlier we visited zillions Keyes
campaign headquarters it has all the
feel of a tech startup but the man
himself gives very few interviews and
his team's power to the people message
is vague at best crane is a business
leader shinya-san let you know when our
Constitution it says that the only one
of political power is the nation for now
unfortunately it's mostly just a
sentence in our Constitution in order
not to have low ratings like our
opponent we need constant feedback from
our citizens we need to set goals
together with them Paula Chad feedback
NASA we apologize
that message has resonated across the
country the zalenski vote in the
elections first round brought together
Ukrainians across the divides of
language and ethnicity and his ratings
have climbed ever since
every time Solinsky speaks Russian the
crowd here start to boo and to say shame
who does look as though he's struggling
more than Petro poroshenko and even
those who Lenski called this debate the
poroshenko side of the stadium is quite
a lot more full than their zillions
p-site but mr. poroshenko has a lot more
to lose I asked him if he thought he'd
be President on Monday
[Music]
definitely who said but if the polls are
anything to go by
you'd have to be very lucky dynamic they
Sky News fear
[Music]